et pour revenir sur cette crise à la
frontière entre la pologne et la
biélorussie
on retrouve tout de suite nos invités
avec nous ce soir françois pour les
matières journaliste spécialiste des
institutions européennes et jean paul
garraud député repères du rassemblement
national bonsoir messieurs merci d'être
avec nous en direct alors comment est-ce
qu'on en est arrivé là d'abord françois
paul et mathis
je crois qu'on allait arriver là tout
simplement parce que il y à une rivalité
qui est évidente maintenant entre d'une
part la biélorussie est derrière la
russie et l'union européenne suit bien
sûr aux sanctions qui ont été décrétées
par l'union européenne notamment
vis-à-vis de la biélorussie après les
élections ratées entre guillemets de
2009 et après notamment la
l'assaisonnement d'un l'arraisonnement
d'un avion pour capturer un opposant ces
sanctions effectivement ont mis en
colère effectivement la biélorussie qui
essaye aujourd'hui de d'utiliser des
moyens j'allais dire assez cynique des
moyens de force pour effectivement faire
plier l'union européenne et la faire
accepter finalement de gêner ces
migrants qui arrivent mais ces migrants
qui arrivent ils sont pas arrivé tout
seul ils sont arrivés grâce à des
agences très organisés qui ont organisé
des départs depuis la zone irako
syrienne vers la biélorussie
et puis tous ces migrants sont arrivés
ont été emmenés vers la frontière vers
la pologne et puis une fois qu'ils y
sont ils ne peuvent plus revenir en
arrière comme canton qu'il sait quelque
chose françois poule et mathilde agence
bien organisés à quoi faites-vous
allusion précisément je fais allusion
des agences bien organisés qu'elles
soient russes ou qu'elle soit biélorusse
qui sont bien sûr pas organiser
directement par le gouvernement pas
forcément mais les gouvernements ni
russe ni biélorusse tour besoin d
organiser ils ont pour cela des agences
qui font le travail et finalement ils
sont bienveillants vis-à-vis ces agences
qui elle achemine tous ces migrants
depuis la zone irako syrienne vers la
frontière polonaise mais le problème
c'est que il pousse tous ces migrants
vers la frontière polonaise ils émettent
en otage système systématiquement en
otages d'une situation qui est
invraisemblable qui est d'un cynisme
épouvantable car effectivement on a
rarement vu une guerre de ce type il
s'agit bien d'une guerre mail une guerre
qui n'utilisent pas des moyens
militaires des moyens armés mais une
guerre qui utilisent des moyens humains
dans des conditions et dans des
circonstances qui sont plutôt
intolérable alors bien sûr cette
situation ll a de quoi choquer jean paul
garraud votre lecture vous de la
situation
oui il ya bien sûr une lecture politique
une lecture humanitaire naturellement je
ne conteste en aucune façon par contre
ce que je souhaite dire ce qu'il ne faut
pas limiter cette question aux problèmes
politiques concernant la biélorussie
parce que ce serait trop simplifier les
choses la réalité est tout autre en
réalité on a un problème de crise'
grattoir général puisque je rappelle
quand même que depuis le début de
l'année
2021 il y à une augmentation
considérable de l'entrée des migrants
une augmentation de 1700 % d'hommes très
les migrants clandestinement dans
l'espace européen dans l'union
européenne par les frontières orientale
de l'union européenne donc ce n'est pas
qu'une question biélorusse cette affaire
c'est une question beaucoup plus général
de crise ligue ratoire en l'occurrence
d'agression mineure at war pourquoi
alors bien sûr pourquoi il faut se poser
la question alors je ne conteste pas
qu'il y ait certaines normes de la part
de la biélorussie une volonté de
rétorsion par rapport à l'union
européenne par rapport aux sanctions
qu'elle m'aime bien lire ici donc subi
de la part de l'union européenne c'est
très vraisemblable oui mais je tire de
chevaux et jean paul garraud votre
appréciation de de la position justement
de bruxelles face à sète à ces migrants
qui sont bloqués donc à la frontière
entre la pologne et la biélorussie
l'union européenne qui refuse de céder
et votre appréciation
l'union européenne est en train de subir
le contrecoup d'une politique migratoire
qu'elle a toujours encouragé si vous
voulez madame la commissaire clara
johnson comme vous l'écoutez ce serait
très bien d'ailleurs de de l'écouté plus
souvent d'une façon plus médiatisé c'est
véritablement une catastrophe telle
politique est une politique qui est
directement
pro-immigration liste mais
d'une façon très importante le 9
novembre dernier madame johansson
s'exprimer au parlement européen et en
disant justement qu'il fallait
encourager il fallait transformer en
gros les migrations illégales en
immigration légale parce que
malheureusement pour des raisons
financières un certain nombre de
migrants ne pouvait pas avoir accès aux
pacers donc elle a dit cela le 9
novembre
à une autre occasion elle s'est exprimée
ou jordan bardel à s'exprimer sur ces
sujets et bien pendant que jordan
bardella s'exprimer sur ces sujets
migratoire très important au parlement
européen madame johansson elle tricotait
le voyez ce que je veux dire donc cesser
vous avez une politique migratoire que
l'union européenne encourage sous des
prétextes démographique parce que nous
aurions besoin de la démographie
apportées par les migrants nous aurions
besoin aussi du travail que les migrants
vont effectuer dans notre pays tout ceci
est dit redit sans arrêt et donc
aujourd'hui on a créé un peu le gard
l'union européenne refuse pour l'instant
de ouvrir sa frontière on a entendu le
témoignage d'ailleurs d'une femme venue
du continent africain 1 recueillies par
notre envoyé spécial on l'a entendu tout
à l'heure c'est à cause de l'union
européenne si nous sommes là dit elle
sur le sort des réfugiés les conditions
humanitaires on dénombre d'ailleurs des
arrestations des refoulements qui pose
question regard du droit international
est ce que à la responsabilité de
l'union européenne est clairement
engagée dans cette crise humanitaire
françois de poule et mathis oui je crois
qu'elle est engagée pour quoi et là je
reviens petit peu sur ce qui vient d
redit ce n'est pas l'union européenne
qui en tant que telle cherche à ouvrir
ses frontières aux immigrés je crois que
le problème c'est que l'union européenne
est en situation d'échec de politique
migratoire sa politique migratoire elle
n'est pas fixée elle n'est pas cohérente
et donc le fait d'avoir d'absence
d'europe fait effectivement que il ya
une certaine forme de laxisme par
rapport à ce problème de l'immigration
sur lequel l'europe est dans
l'incapacité actuellement de s'organiser
pour gérer collectivement ce problème il
ya des contradictions absolument
épouvantable on voit par exemple de cas
pays comme la pologne et c'est le comble
qui émerge l' agence frontex de
surveillance des frontières et bien que
la pologne refuse l'aide ou l'apport de
l' agence frontex à ses frontières ça
montre bien cette contradiction qui à la
fois on voudrait que l'europe fasse tout
mais à la fois on fait en sorte que
l'europe soit impuissante et les
nationalismes ressortent et ces
nationalistes sont un frein épouvantable
à toute solution qui pourrait être une
solution concertée entre les différents
pays européens c'est là qu'est le
véritable problème alors on voit ces
réfugiés prise au piège d'un bras de fer
entre minsk d'une part à
varsovie et bruxelles justement jean
paul garraud l'allemagne fait appel à la
russie pour que moscou interviennent
dans cette crise la dîmière poutine le
président russe a appelé justement
l'union européenne à reprendre le
dialogue avec la biélorussie que peut
faire mouscou concrètement hormis
conseillé aux européens de discuter
que déjà mais difficile de dire ce que
peut faire la russie est naturellement
jeu d'autant plus que c'est pas dans ma
nature de dire aux autres pays et ce
qu'ils doivent eux faire je respecte la
souveraineté de tous ces pays je reviens
juste un instant en arrière à ce qu'on
reprochait la pologne ne pas faire de ne
pas disons faire signe à frontex et
pourquoi pourquoi la pologne ne le fait
pas tout simplement parce que la fronde
30 textes c'est pas du tout des
gardes-frontières contrairement à ce que
les gens peuvent croire frontex c'est
une agence en quelque sorte d'accueil
des migrants voilà est là actuellement
si vous voulez la pologne ne peut pas
faire appel agence puisque cette agence
ne va pas du tout joué un rôle de garde
frontières je voudrais dire aussi qu'il
y a quand même 12 pays membres de
l'union européenne et pas des moindres
si je puis dire l'autriche naturellement
la république tchèque la pologne bien
entendu la hongrie et d'autres qui ont
demandé à l'union européenne à la
commission européenne d'avoir des moyens
pour protéger leurs frontières je leurs
frontières extérieures à l'union
européenne je rappelle que je ne parle
pas des frontières intérieures sur
locales y ait des discussions je parle
des frontières extérieures moi j'ai
toujours entendu que à commencer
d'ailleurs par emmanuel macron qui a dit
qu'il fallait descendre les frontières
extérieures de l'europe nous sommes là
dans un débat sur les frontières
extérieures de l'europe et en
l'occurrence des frontières orientales
et bien l'union européenne s'en lave les
mains elle ne veut pas donner les moyens
à ces pays 2 justement faire en sorte de
pouvoir se défendre
il ya juste le garage et qu'on veut mais
je ne m'aimais sur nos raisonnements
pourrait résoudre ce problème d'un point
de vue financier la souveraineté de ces
pays ne doit pas être violées et je ne
suis pas du tout d'accord avec le fait
que l'union européenne puisse avoir une
politique en matière migratoire surtout
pas parce que si l'union européenne peut
légiférer en matière migratoire je peux
vous assurer qu'on va voir d'ailleurs
avec le pacte européen sur l'immigration
et l'asile qui doit être appliquée
bientôt on va avoir 60 à 70 millions et
bigrement qui vont arriver sur notre
évidemment ne sont notre espace européen
alors la catastrophe humanitaire dont on
parle on va l'avoir ici on va la voir en
france parce qu'on ne pourra pas
accueillir toute la mesure toute la
misère du monde
c'est terrible d'autres l'ont dit avant
moi mais c'est la réalité donc la
politique de l'union européenne ne doit
pas être une politique qui favorise
toutes ces pompes aspirantes à
l'immigration on précipite c'est
malheureux parce qu'ils croient bien sûr
qu'ils vont être chez nous bien mieux
que chez eux et alors qu'on devrait
prendre toute une série de mesures avec
les pays en question les pays qui
envoient entre guillemets tout c'est
tout m
j'en reviens à ma question parce que la
solution pour
résoudre justement cette crise urgente
elle et diplomatique actuellement je
reviens à ma question il ya une volonté
de la part de l'union européenne de
faire intervenir la russie est ce que la
solution c'est celle ci
écoutez que la russie interviennent ce
très bien pourquoi on se passerait de
l'avis de la russie naturellement la
russie d'une grande puissance ici elle
peut avoir de sens est dans cette
affaire un rôle qui puisse débloquer la
situation il faut bien sûr l'utiliser
naturellement et j'espère que
effectivement le fera sans avoir des
oeillères c'est le problème dans toute
cette affaire c'est que au niveau
européen et de l'idéologie de l'union
européenne souvent il ya justement des
oeillères françois pour les mathis alors
la biélorussie inquiets menace de
couper l'approvisionnement en gaz
justement vers l'union européenne
il s'agit de fermer la vanne du gazoduc
yamal-europe qui est gérée par le géant
russe gazprom qui traverse quatre pays
on rappelle la biélorussie la pologne
l'allemagne mais la russie également et
surtout alors justement est-ce que la
biélorussie a les moyens de ses
ambitions est ce qu'elle peut se
permettre de passer à l'acte je ne suis
pas sûr que les que la russie a les mots
enfin que la biélorussie a les moyens de
ses ambitions pourquoi parce que
l'approvisionnement en gaz de l'europe
c'est très important effectivement en
période de recrudescence des prix de
l'énergie c'est effectivement une menace
qui doit peser mais il faut savoir aussi
que pour la russie ce serait une menace
et la russie n'a probablement pas
intérêt du tout ap a provoqué une
coupure de l'acheminement du gaz vers
l'europe et donc je pense finalement que
je crois pas trop de solutions clie
peut-être des coupures partielles ou
quelques quelques menaces partiel mais
de couper définitivement un réseau aussi
important que yamal europe c'est
absolument invraisemblable et la russie
ne l'accepterai pas c'est pour ça que je
ne crois pas beaucoup à cette solution
je crois qu'il y aura une solution la
solution vient du fait que comme il n'y
a par exemple entre la turquie le maroc
et l'europe et il ya des accords pour
maintenir les réfugiés
avant la frontière vers l'union
européenne il n'y a pas de ce type
d'accord avec la biélorussie il faudra
d'une certaine manière arriver à un
arrangement pour qu'il y ait un accord
effectivement pour que
certains de ces immigrés puissent être
retenue ça fait partie des solutions
possibles mais de toute façon on ne peut
pas continuer à ignorer la réalité la
réalité c'est que les migrants ignorent
les frontières nationales de l'europe
ils ne savent pas ce que c'est les
migrants niveau en dans l'union
européenne d'ailleurs la personne
africaine qui a été interviewé tout à
leur dire j'en veux à l'europe parce que
c'est l'europe qui doit répondre c'est
l'europe qui doit répondre et c'est pas
ni la pologne ni la france ni
l'allemagne c'est l'europe que les gens
attendent et cette europe
malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est vrai
elle est un peu absente c'est ce qui
fait sa faiblesse alors les critiques on
peut faire contre l'europe sont réels
elle sort elle du fait de l'absence de
concertation et de l'absence de
coordination c'est ça le véritable
problème c'est pas qu'il faut moins
d'europe au contraire il faut plus
d'europe
l'europe qui agite d'ailleurs la menace
de nouvelles sanctions merci à vous
françois poulet mathis journalistes
spécialisés institutions européennes et
avoue jean paul garraud député européen
du rassemblement national